Yeah Good afternoon,
everyone. What if
we tell you that Phillips was
able to migrate their 20,000+
critical
Medicare devices
from the legacy
machine to machine communication back end
to more modern event-driven
serverless architecture to
integrate with the modern IoT
platform to gain
more reliability, scalability
at the same time.
Result into the cost avoidance
of 20 million plus.
It is an exciting story, right?
And we are going to tell you how we
achieve that and how we transform
the legacy back end systems into
the more modern architectures
using event driven and serverless
and for that.
I am Anand Bulgia. I'm an
enterprise transformation specialist
and a senior partner solution architect
with AWS, and I'm joined by Shrini
Shrini. Good afternoon
everyone. I know we are between
the last session and the replay,
so we'll keep it
short, excited, um,
you all must have heard of Phillips as a
brand,
so the toothbrushes, the shavers,
uh, but what Anand was talking
about is the critical care
devices that we have
which are related to the.
Diagnostics and treatment devices
like the integrated um
IGT devices,
CT scanners,
X-ray machines.
So I am Sriniva Seram, platform
architecture lead in digital innovation
platforms,
and we are going to talk about how
in our organization
we have
used the event driven architecture to connect
our legacy devices to a modern integrated
services from the back end.
So we'll first let Anan continue
giving an introduction about event driven architecture,
and I'll come back in between
to walk through the use case and
uh how everything comes together.
Anan, sure,
thanks, Vinnie.
So this is how our
agenda look like for the next hour or so.
We are going to talk about why event driven architecture,
why they matters for the modern applications,
and then
we also wanna look about the Phillips case study.
What were the business requirement? What are the challenges,
and how
the modern event driven architecture help us to mitigate
those. And then we are going to look about
some of the event driven architecture pattern.
Which could help us to transform
those legacy systems into the more
modernized state and last but not the
least, the most important one, the end to end
solution what we were able to build
to gain those business outcome in terms of
scalability, reliability, and avoiding
that cost, uh, right,
for 20 million which otherwise, uh,
would have been the part of the overall transformation.
So first thing first,
what is even driven architecture?
Now if I have to give you
a very simplistic, non-technical
definition,
and I will
explain that
in one statement.
Something happened and we react.
This is the event of an architecture.
Some systems are doing some
business processes and they are
then expecting the other component
of the system and the architecture to react
and that's where the event driven architecture
comes. Into the play
now if I move into the more technical definition
now why even driven architectures
are used they are used to build
more decoupled
applications where the different
component in the decoupled state
can communicate with each other via
emitting the events and then
responding to those events. Now if we
take an example of. Modern applications, right, modern
applications are complex,
right, because they are distributed in
nature. Take an example of microservices
based architecture. Microservices based architecture
requires many different layers
in the levers in terms of the different domain
services which need to communicate with each
other and sometimes
if the distributed components have a tight integration
between them, it impacts the overall scalability,
reliability, and the agility.
Of the architectures and that's where
the event driven architecture helps to
define more decoupled
asynchronous way of dealing
the communication between these uh uh
architectural components right?
So
the first class citizen
of the event of an architecture is an
event itself. Now if I, if I have to
define what is the definition,
a sim simplistic definition of event
could be a something which has
happened.
So event represent.
Something which has happened in your system
and always represented into the past
means they are idempotent.
Something which has already happened which cannot be
changed, but.
It's what the event represents
something which you, as a domain care
about. If I take
an example of the healthcare devices itself,
the event could be my healthcare devices
are registered,
right, so that they can start interacting,
uh, with the back end system
for performing the operation what they're supposed to do,
right? The event could be, OK, the file
has been received now start processing it, right?
Or the event could be there are some security alert
which need to get imme uh which required your
imme immediate attention to mitigate those, right.
So event driven architectures are all revolve
around the
events right now let's talk about
what are some of the design tenet or the properties
of the event driven architecture, right?
Why they met why the event driven architecture matter,
right, for the modern applications.
The very first thing, the event driven architecture,
it's not a tool, it's not a technology,
but it's an architectural mindset, right,
which help us.
To build
a decomposed the decoupled
systems, right, so it's architectural
style and even driven architecture can be implemented
in various different ways. It
depends upon what is the nature of the workload
you are dealing with, and we are going to tap upon
some of these different ways in which
the even driven architecture can be built as
we go along subsequently in our session.
The second thing, event-driven architectures
are asynchronous, and that's why they
are loosely coupled. So the so the components
between the event driven architecture do not
directly
tightly integrated with each other. They
asynchronously communicate with each other. So
it's typical.
So we are converging from a typical request
response based model to more an
event-based responsive model, right?
The third, the event autonomy. What
does it mean for event event architecture?
It is very important that the event should
be self-contained, so event.
Contain the information about.
Why they get created, why they were
imitated, who imited them or
who created them,
and when.
They were created so this information is
important for the subsequent downstream
system
to consume these events and act accordingly,
right? So event autonomy is important and
last but not the least as I mentioned
the. How the event different architect
architecture works,
some components are emitting the event and the
other component in the system are actually responding
to those events. It's as simple as simple
as that, right? So these are the different properties,
right, which define the event-driven
architecture.
Now we have seen
event driven architecture. We have seen
the, the, the, the
events which are the critical and the
uh integral part of the event event architecture sit
in the center of the EDA
and we also seen some of the properties of
event even architecture.
Now let's look into what are some
of the
Benefit we get
from this event driven architecture.
The first benefit, as I mentioned, is the loose
coupling and the agility. Why
the agility matters the most? Because the
event driven architecture allows us to
then build the system in
parallel,
agnostic or independent to each
other, and that does not impact your
overall
release cycle
for. Releasing the new different features
what matter the most for your business so the team
can go and independently build the systems
and they can just communicate
the communication between these channels or these
application components can happen can happen
over the network via
emitting the event and consuming the event, right.
The scalability, right,
because the event driven architecture are more responsive
so, so
the independently the components can
be scaled based on their business
needs, right?
More res the event of an architecture bring more
resiliency in the architecture because
they are loosely coupled they're running in parallel
independently agnostic to each other
so if any components has got any
challenges or any failure, it is not
creating a downstream or cascading
effect and impacting your entire business
continuity.
And last but not the least, it manages
the complex integrations as I mentioned,
the distributed system, the modern
applications, they have a lot of complexities
involved in terms of the different, uh,
building block and the event driven architecture
abstract that integration
complexities because
the competents are now
decoupled to each other. They're agnostic to each other.
They just react based on the events
which flow between them.
Right? So
we looked into the EDA properties. We
looked into the event driven architecture's benefits.
Now look into some of the core building
block of event-driven architecture using
which we actually established the EDA
in our, um, uh, uh, in
our, in our applications based on the business requirements.
The very first thing is event
we have already talked about.
The second thing is event routers. So as
I mentioned, how the event driven architecture works,
there are some producers, there's some component
who are actually producing the event. We call
them as a producer.
And there are some components which are actually
consuming those events and
responsing and and they are
responding accordingly uh to those events
so we call them as a consumer
what event router does they actually.
Sit between the producer and consumer
and allow this communication happen
so it's the event router who will then
take a ownership of how the
event should flow from producer to
consumer,
right? And the third component
is the event store. Often the
time
you may
require the consumer
to consume the event and act
accordingly whenever they are available.
So you need some sort of an intermediate
store where these events can get
stored and they can get replay
as and when the bus as and when
it is needed, right, based on your business
processes and the business flow
requirements, right? So these are the three
building blocks.
We use to define or build the
event driven architecture.
Let's take a simple example, how the overall
event driven architecture looked like, right?
Let's say
We are in the world, we are, we are generating a lot
of data, a lot of content. So let's say we are generating
some data. It could be your images, it could be your
document, right? And those data we
are storing in our Amazon
Simple storage Service in S3. The
moment
the document gets stored or uploaded,
we want to perform certain action
on top of that. Let's take an example of
a critical medical devices.
If let's say the X-ray or MRI has been
done, you want to then.
And do the analysis of those X-ray
or MRI reports so that you can
accordingly generate the outcome and the summary
and push back to the respective, uh, clinical
team, right?
So the document is uploaded to the S3.
The S3 as a service can emit
an event that the file has been uploaded.
And once the file is uploaded, that
can that event can be consumed
by an event router, and we are taking
an example of Amazon Event Bridge, which
is our
service which helps
us to define.
The event driven architecture and we will
go into the more detail
of how event bridge works and what are its properties
and what are some of the design patterns which we can
build. Around it right,
and then event router will consume,
take this, uh, event,
do some sort of, uh, filtering, apply
certain rule based according to your business need,
and then it push it to the target
system. The target system could be your
logic, business logic, which then
take that image and then do the
cert for her, you know, the certain analysis
and then generate the outcome or the
summary. So in our case,
the producer was the, the document
store. Consumer was our lambda
function which is running a business logic to process
that X-ray image or MRI image and
in between sitting as an event router
which is making sure the communication
happens
between these two these two components
over the
over the events, right? And this is how
the event event architecture looked like now
with this let's try to understand
the Phillips business case
right? and then.
We will
take it from there on
to look into the various different,
you know, the advanced EDA patterns and
the end to end solution, right, which we
were able to build for this Phillips use case.
So Srini, over to you.
Thank you Anan.
First, let me set the context.
How many of you have dealt with
more than 1,000s of devices in the field?
A quick show of hands.
OK.
Around maybe 20%.
How many of you from healthcare dealing
with legacy systems in the field?
OK, a few.
It will definitely resonate to you of
what I'm going to show
because.
The devices that we ship
to these healthcare facilities,
the critical care devices,
they connect to our back end systems,
and
Phillips has been connecting these devices
for a long time and.
These devices, they connect into our back end.
Uh, this is, um, they are sending
the, uh, log file information.
And normally what happens is this log file
information are
processed. There is an alert that gets
generated
to a remote service engineer.
The remote service engineer can remotely connect
to the device and see if he can
resolve the issue.
In some cases,
He will not be able to do it by himself,
so he would
dispatch a service request with a
field change order to a field service
engineer,
and the field service engineer will travel
to the specific location
where the device is and he will try to
fix it. This is a
general serviceability flow.
This is how
Phillips has been trying to deal
with serviceability. Services is a larger,
uh, business model within Phillips because once
we ship the device, we want those
devices to be up and running 24/7
in the hospital systems.
Now the fundamental challenge that we had,
like in any system,
the legacy M2M systems
that we have
had its own end of life.
And it came so fast to
us and slowly as well. We had
known it many years ago, so we
replaced with a modern remote
services gateway.
But in this case, there were certain devices
that could not be updated in time.
So that was the use case that Anand
was speaking about. We have roughly around
these 20,000
X-ray machines and image
guided therapy devices
that have an agent that connect to
these legacy devices that cannot be updated.
Now if we do a little bit math
around this,
a simple trip
off an FSC
costs around $1000
and if we just calculate
just to restore the connectivity of these
devices,
it costs us around roughly $20
million. Just to restore the connectivity.
And our requirement was
to make sure that
we have to deal with this in a time
frame, which was December 31st,
2024.
So this has already passed
through, so we have gone through and that's why we're able
to talk about it now.
So we, our requirements were very simple,
OK? We have to replace the end
of life M2M.
Which are affecting these 20,000 devices.
Now it has to be
zero disruption.
And zero touch solution.
If we have to touch the devices, then the FSC
has to travel, and that again is
a cost to us.
And then of course, we have to maintain
these devices because they're in the field
and we have our contractual
obligations to meet these
devices up and running.
The other challenge was
the architecture itself,
so our challenges were twofold. One, the
way how the architecture is of
what has, uh, the
M2M systems were in the
field.
Um, there were many services. It's
a monolith services, API driven.
I don't know how many of you will resonate
with you. These are so based web
services, sim simple object access protocol,
and you can imagine how old these systems
are in the back end.
And for making these systems
complex enough,
there is an ESB enterprise service
bus that sit sits in between
and makes these these services
talk to each other.
And of course, there's a lot of complexity
or a period of time because we have added
so many workflows, so many use cases.
And then, of course, these
services themselves, they do a lot,
uh, because of the, um, uh,
the complexity of workflows over a period of
time. In
order for us to actually
solve this,
one was the architecture of the way how
the backing system was, and then
I would say we can sell the challenges in
fivefold.
One, because we have to
translating since we said
the devices cannot be touched, there
is a legacy API,
and you know when APIs reside
in your system for 10 years, you lose
the documentation about them.
Um, generally it's tribal knowledge.
Somebody knows somewhere, you wouldn't have
the full documentation to start with.
And because these devices have been
living in the field for so many years,
there are multiple versions of the clients.
So of course we know which client
we are dealing with, but if you have
20,000 devices and you have 7
versions of the clients,
you would have to understand how those
clients behave when interacting with the back
end system.
And I was talking about how
the workflows have become
complex for just for
heartbeat we have something called
true reachability
where we say whether a device is up and running
and the devices sends a ping
that particular workflow itself has become
so complex even though somebody says oh
just a ping to my back end system
but. We will have to say whether
is this device connecting from
where it should be.
Sometimes some of these devices do are,
are mobile-based as well, right?
And then of course we are in a compliance ecosystem,
so anything we touch
has to be compliant from a regulatory
standpoint.
And then
the
scale of the solution
cannot be done
at like one go,
and I'll come to it in a minute because.
As I was saying, these 20,000 devices,
we cannot replicate them in our test
environment.
So this is production data that we are trying
to deal with and in order for us
to,
um,
figure out what is the best solution
or the patterns that we want to apply
for it,
we have to understand how these systems
in the field are behaving.
We did not, we do not have a good
digital twin
kind of an ecosystem that we can play
around and see, oh, this system behaves
in this way with this version versus this
system behaves,
and this is, I'm talking about
25 product lines over
the last 10 years,
so it, it just becomes
complicated.
So these were our challenges. I think I
have introduced the use case. I will
let Anand come in,
dive a little bit deeper into some of the
patterns that we would have
leveraged or we would have thought
best to solve this problem.
Thanks, Renee.
So what we saw, what Sydney just explained,
what police was having earlier,
a legacy machine to machine
back end which has taken a form
of typical monolithic right
now the first thing
we have to do is
how we can decompose this monolithic
into a more modular
uh you know, decoupledle architecture, right?
and. For
that, let's look into how the EDA
can help us,
too. Define
a new architectural style for a given monolithic
application which is more even driven and
more
decoupled. So the first thing is
you do not just go and decompose
the application from its
implementation perspective because whatever
implementation you are doing. Whatever
technology it is representing your business
behaviors, so it's very important to
understand your business processes first, your
domain first, and then you try to rearchitect
your existing business processes via
applying the architectural patterns, right? So
understanding of the domain is very important.
Once you
understood the domain, the second thing is then you
design. The events
around the domain because as I mentioned we are talking about
the event event architecture so everything will
go around the events it's become very
important to identify what are the relevant.
Domain events which matter the most
for your business services for your customers,
and once you have identified that then
around those events you apply
the right event driven architecture
pattern as I mentioned EDA can be
implemented in various different ways,
right? It depend upon the nature of
your workload, the nature of your business
processes you adopt the
right pattern according to your need.
And last but not the least, once you've
identified the pattern, you have the solution
ready. Now implementation of
that solution then happens via
leveraging our AWS
serverless, even even architectural
services capacities, right?
Which make it super fast to build
the event driven architecture for your business
applications, right?
So let's first look into the domain.
Let's start with the domain, right?
Let's do the things architecturally
right, right?
So what is the toughest, toughest part? The
toughest part
is to how do we decompose
this monolithic application into the more
modular
microservices based architecture,
right? Now why it
is important, it is important because as we know, monolithic
applications are complex.
They have a lot of challenges though
in terms of their scalability. If you have to scale
any part of the,
uh, monothic application, you end up deploying
the entire application which increased a lot of
operational overhead has also increased your cost
and as well as
any issue in any part of your application
may. Bog down the
entire application so it also impact your business
continuity, right?
So they're not scalable, they're not reliable, right?
Operational also there are challenges with the monolithics.
It's always better to transform these monolithic
into the more modern architecture like a
microservices based architecture, like an event
driven based architecture, and how
this can be. But the question is
how do I break my legacy monolithic
application you talked about, OK,
understand the domain.
How will I understand the domain? Who can
help me to understand the domain?
What is the process around it? So,
so. What happens
often we have seen the
application owners, they go, they start
the journey of decomposing any monolithic
into the more decoupled architectures,
but they fall into certain pitfalls. Now
what are those pitfalls? The very first pit pitfall
is the distributed monolithic.
They try to and distributed monolithic
can happen via applying the horizontal
tiering. What the application owners try to
do, they try to group the related
components, the similar components of the
application together and then carve out the
different. Uh,
different Smaller
smaller sub module out of your monolithic
application, right?
And then they try to decompose this
application in this way, right?
So they take a monolithic, they try to
merge the similar components which are
interacting to each other
in a single group, and they try to converge
into the smaller, smaller
sub module of the application
which again take a shape of the smaller monolithic
application and they all inherit the challenges
of otherwise the monolithic application
have. The 2nd pitfall
in which the application owner falls into
is the nanoservices,
and that happens by applying the vertical tiering.
So they look into the different functionality
from the UI perspective, from the web
user interface perspective, how the end user is interacting
with their application,
and they try to split the application functionality
based on those UI screens. And imagine
an app if you have an application which has 100,000s
of the uh user features, right,
or the screens, then you may end up having
multiple services, and that creates a lot
of chattiness in your environment.
So how this works, sorry.
So you have a monolithic and you are actually
decomposing into the multiple smaller granular
services and
that create operational overhead because managing
uh many services are challenging at the same
time you also need
to think about the lot of chattiness with
this application can create in the environment
and that's where the right granularity is
a key. So how do we achieve this right
granularity?
So the right granularity can be achieved
when we have a right understanding
of our domain.
From the business owner and the
application owners, so if our
business owners and the application owners
are having the common understanding of the
domain,
then they can define the right boundaries
and the right granularity in which
any given monolithic applications should get
decomposed.
And one such architectural practice and the
methodologies we have seen customers using.
Is a domain driven design
which was first talked about by the Eric Ivan.
What did he mention? He mentioned
for any software development.
The technology should not be the first focus.
Rather, the business process and the activities
which need to get supported by the
technology should be the focus, right? So
the domain driven design help us
to get the details
around the domain and bring the
application owners, the domain owners and the domain expert
and the application expert and application owner.
On the same understanding, right, so that they
can take the right decision. Take example of
health care, the use case what we are talking about
for us, the domain is healthcare.
Under that domain there could be a multiple
subdomains. For example, we are talking, we
are taking a case of critical
medical healthcare devices around
imaging, for example, X-rays, right?
And then, so this, these become the imaging
become the one of the subdomain.
And under the subdomain you need to define what
are some of the core functionality which matter
the most for my business which I want to transform,
which I want to decompose, right? So
this analysis can be done
using the domain driven design. I'm
not going to go into the much detail of this
subject because you can have your.
Uh, you know, the, uh, reading around
this topic, uh, right, uh, I recommend
that, uh, you know, go through the, what are the
some of the design principle around the domain
driven design, but this helps, right, the business
owner and, uh, applicationer to
have the shared understanding, right?
But OK,
domain driven design can help us to
understand the domain,
right, but, uh, Alberto Brandolini,
right, he's the inventor of the event storming,
he's, he.
Mention a very interesting quote
like whatever goes into the production is
not always the expert knowledge of the domain
expert rather the understanding
or misunderstanding of the developers, and
that's what's happened. You need to make sure
your application owners are understanding
your domain,
uh, perfectly fine according to the
business owners need and the business
owners are also aligned to that.
And how do we get that?
How do we convert our application owners or
application team into the domain expert?
One of the ways to do this is.
leveraging
The events and
start understanding the domain by
identifying the different
events which are happening in your
business processes and that's where we are going
to talk about the second phase of the event driven architecture
journey now that how do we design these
events and how we can design and identify
the events right?
uh, for your given application.
That can be done by using event storming,
right? And event storming is
another architectural methodology which can
be adopted to identify
the different events which are happening in your system.
Let's take the example of the event could be the divide
got registered right now. And
what are the commands which are actually
got exec which are getting executed in your system
to generate those events? Who are the producer of those
events? Who should be the consumer of those events?
What should be the some external system which
should care about those events? So all
this analysis can be done by using
event storming. Now event storming is again
like a domain event design is architectural style
is a methodology. I will encourage you
to go through it so that you can
apply this pattern to identify,
uh,
in your business requirement and so that you
can get a right shared understanding
of your given,
uh, business domain, right?
So what happens, so decomposition, how
it happens, so it happens via.
Domain event, so we call it as a domain
driven, uh, you know, domain event
driven decomposition. So in this
case domain driven design and the event
storming.
The knowledge of both the architectural
mythologies can come together
to identify the right microservices boundaries
for you. How this happened, you perform the domain analysis
and then you apply the event storming
in that domain to identify the
respective events and then from
there you go into the respective bounded context.
So each domain service. Will have its own
context under which it wants to
perform the certain capabilities, right? For
example, if I have a device registration service, what
should be the capability of the device registration service?
What are the tasks is supposed to do? So
that understanding is nothing but the bounded context
which can be arrived using using this
particular methodology. And last but not the
least, each bounded context then converge
into. The right microservices, right? So
let's look into the one example how the event
storming output can look like for
a device registration flow.
So we identify in event storming
exercise who are the actor. Actor could be a
device. It could be a machine. It could be the user
in our Phillips Healthcare use
case, it is a device who is currently
going to emit some events, so it become a
producer. Now
device
perform a command.
Let's say register me, register device.
It's a new device which is getting onboarded to any medical
facility, it will emit a command register
me. Then this command will
actually
produce some event. OK, the device is registered
and this event
may have some 10 business policies.
For example, before registering the device,
validate the device
is.
The device is ready to get
on boarded so that the medical
information, clinical information get get start
getting exchanged from the device. So we
identify the business policy and
there could be uh external systems
as well for uh right, uh,
who also care about those events. So
when the device is registered, maybe
the connection is established and the external system
want to then start communicating
with your different back end processes.
And consume that information which has been
emitted by the device. So this,
the entire domain driven design and even storming analysis
can help you to define these workflows, and
these workflows will be defined by your application owner
and the business owner together. And then
this, the intent here is you combine
the related domain events and
then convert to the granular
boundaries and the granular microservices.
So with this and what we do, what
we did, we applied the same design principle,
domain domain design and even test storming.
In the Philips legacy
machine to machine back end system and then we converge
into the different services
with the right granularity so we
could converge to the services, for
example, registration service which take care of the
registering the device,
the alert service where the when the
device send the alerts how to consume and how to act on
that, the file transfer because these
devices will be keep sending the data
at a certain frequency, how we can consume
that and process them,
and the polling service as.
I was mentioning for you know checking the
health of the devices and then there was
a communication which was happening
between these devices via applying the synchronous
architecture or even even architecture which
we'll see in a moment right
now what advantage we get by applying
these architectural techniques and the methodologies
we converse to the microservices which does
not do which does not perform multiple
things which does uh one thing but
one thing right, and it has its own APIs,
its own business logic, its own data
under which
it actually.
Uh, get, uh, deployed.
So what are the benefit we get with the,
uh, microservices based architecture? You
can independently build them,
you know, independently deploy them and independently
scale them, right?
And they, you can then leverage
the power of the elastic, um.
Infrastructure from cloud to accordingly
scale them based on, you know, your business
needs and you can make them as a reusable
um uh you can apply
them apply on them a usable pattern
you can deploy them as a container you can deploy them
as a serverless architecture, right?
A lot thing can be done, uh. When
you converge to the modern microservices
based architecture.
Now we have converged from a
legacy API driven monolithic
to the API driven microservices,
but is it enough?
Are we saying that my architecture is now having
all the right patterns in the tenants?
Maybe not.
Why? Because each architecture has
got its own consideration.
Modern thing was having some considerations.
We solve those using
micro surfaces based architecture, but the microservices
based architecture also requires certain considerations.
Now what are those?
Let's dig into those.
How the services communicate with each other.
Each microservice
will be communicating over each other
over a network.
Now let's say for a given business
process there are multiple service services
need to act together
and they need to work together, communicate together
for the fulfillment of fulfillment of that request. So
how it will happen? Service A communicating with the service
B. Service B, go and reach
out to the service C, and the response
is then
written back in the reverse manner.
Now there could be a different possibilities,
right? What if the, if the service B goes down?
What if the service C is slow?
So a lot of different design considerations which
are also need to be. Consider when we are building
a microservices based architecture. So
one choice is consistency versus ability
standard cap theorem problem.
Do you want all your system to see the same
consistent state versus you want your
system to be always available to react
for the requests.
The latency versus throughput,
what matters the most, the how fast you
get the response versus how many requests
you can manage, right, for a given system.
The coupling versus performance, the more it
is tightly coupled, the performance is
you can achieve a better performance, but
you are also increasing the tight couple, uh,
the tight integration between your component,
right? And then definitely if your
complex business flows required a
transactionality means multiple systems
need to act together
in the atomicity, consistency, isolation,
and durability that become the complex affair
as well, right?
So how do we handle this, and that's
where we need to apply the right event
driven architecture pattern to solve
some of these challenges in the modern
complex distributed microservices systems.
And now let's look into some of those
event driven architecture patterns.
So very so as we know the, the,
the, the, the concept of the inventive
architecture, as I mentioned, there are producers,
there are consumer,
producer emit the event, consumer consume
the event, right now we need to
see how we solve this puzzle, how the communication
from producer to the consumer should happen over
the events and what are the different ways in which
it can happen.
So it's, so one of the way it
should happen is
the cue-based communication.
So you have the producers or the senders who
are sending the messages and.
Those messages are receivers
receiving it
over a queue, so there is a queue in between, and
this queue is actually storing those messages
and then
each consumer is consuming these messages from
the queue. Now this kind of patterns are
useful where you need to have some
sort of a transactionality involved where you want
a single message to be consumed by
the single. Single,
uh, single message should be consumed by the single consumer
itself. For example,
if my devices are emitting an event
like register device,
then I do not want the device
to get registered multiple times. So I need
that transactional ID. I want that
that particular registered device message to
get consumed once and
processed ones.
So this kind of.
Architecture help us to define those
uh uh you know, to handle
those use cases in our Phyllis
RSG use case. The second is the stream
based in certain scenario
where what happens you have senders
who are emitting the events or the messages
you
may want to replay them more. Than
once, for example,
if the device is sending certain alert, you
want to keep notifying the end user
or the admin or the relative staff
to fix that problem. There are some challenges
and you want to do that at a certain frequency,
so you want to
replay the event right at certain frequency.
So you will leverage the stream-based,
uh, communication between
the producer and the consumer.
AWS help you to build
this. Pull base, uh,
uh, you know, the event, uh,
driven architecture via providing the AWS native
services like Amazon SQS.
From the queuing perspective and from the streaming
perspective it is Amazon uh
Kinesis
and from the menaces if you want
open source, uh, uh,
uh, technology to to define your EDA architecture,
then it could be done by using Amazon MQ,
uh, from the queuing perspective and from the streaming
perspective we also have a manage
service for Kafka.
Right, so this so
far what we have seen is the pool-based architecture.
What does it mean? Here the consumer are actually
pulling the information. The consumer will pull
the messages from the queue. The consumer
will pull the messages from the stream,
right? So in this case, the consumer is actually
taking the additional,
uh, behavior of pulling
the messages. Trying the messages right
now let's also look into the, the other architectural
pattern which is a push base.
Now again we have a same producer of the
event on the left hand side and we have a
consumer of the messages on the right hand side
now but in this case we introduce
a concept called service bus.
So what this service bus does.
Leveraging the service was we can configure
the different rules
for all the ingress events
and we can define
for based on the rule validation
what should be the probable target to
which these events should go uh for the
consumer and that's that is
called an event bus based communication
pattern within the EDA
and. In this case
it's an event router which is a service to us
which take a responsibility of pushing
these events to the consumer rather than consumer
is consuming them or pulling them which we
saw in the
previous po based model.
The other way it could be done is using
the topic-based architecture as well where we
have a publisher.
Publisher is uh also publishing
the messages and we define the different
topic and there are consumers who can
subscribe to the related topic and
whenever the producer is pushing any message
to the topic all the subscriber
who are part who have subscribed to that topic
they all get. The messages or
the notification a typical publisher subscriber
pattern what we are talking about, right? And
AWS does support,
uh, this capability as well via
different native as well as the open source
manage services in case of
event bus space architecture we have a.
Event bridge and in case of topic-based architecture
we have a SNS
and also for the manage open source
we have Amazon and Q, right?
So how the overall end to end EDA
implementation look like, right? So
as I mentioned, we could have a different event
producers. Those could be your AWS services,
those could be your microservices. Those could
be your third party SAS application
emitting an event and let's say the event bridge
as a router is consuming those events,
applying the rules, doing the filtering, and
then configuring the target
to push this event to the
different consumers like running a
different workflows, for example, if device
registration is a multi. Step
process then that process need to get kick
in and that could be
done by you know invoking our
uh workflow business process workflow via step
function or maybe you know
notifying the admin if there are some device alert
using the SNS or maybe
pushing these events or the messages
to the other back end downstream microservices
if transactionallyport
transactionality is important and multiple services need
to act together
for the fulfillment of the business requirement.
Right? So
I think yeah this is the previous slide.
Now with this now we have
understood the end to end event driven
architecture
uh uh patterns and how the communication
happen. Yeah
Sure, now I'll quickly go into the
how we have adopted some of these patterns
for our PLS, uh, machine to
machine communication backend transformation.
So we define the Phyllis RG service as we
saw earlier, and then these services
are emitting the event like registration of the
devices.
File transfer uh for these devices
and these
events were captured in the
event was which we build using the
Amazon event bridge and we defined
the certain rules which were getting
applied to these different events
and then.
Based on those rules and validation, we
were executing the different flow. For example,
if it is a registration of the device, we were
executing the registration workflow using our step
function. If it is a file
transfer for which the file transfer
need the once the file is transferred, the
processing of the file has to happen in the back end.
For that it's a dedicated queue to which
we need to push these messages for our
file transfer service. So we are pushing these
messages and even to the dedicated queue for that
service or. It could be the alert,
right? We have to consume the alert and act accordingly.
So this is how we were able to manage
the communication using even even
architecture between the difficult
between the different medical care,
uh, RSD services as well as the
respecting business processes or their dedicated
cues, right?
The other was the choreography pattern.
The choreography pattern is very important,
which comes handy when you have a diff you're
dealing with a different domain services, and each
services need to communicate with each
other
across the domain boundaries. And in our RSG
use case, the remote services gateway use
case for the FLIS, we had exactly the similar
requirement where the different services
like registration, file transfer, and alert
need to.
Also had an interaction with the different
architectural uh components
like workflows,
the messaging cues, and we were doing
that via
interacting or communication,
communicating these services with
the different business processes using
the event, right?
And this choreography pattern
what we have built,
we have built using the Amazon event
page. So left hand side we have our services, right hand side
we have a step function, messaging cues, and
all those are getting integrated to each other
over the event using the survey bus.
The last but not the least is the orchestration
pattern.
Take an example of the device registration flow
again. The device registration is a multi-step
process. It first need to validate
the device.
If the validation is successful, it register the
device. If the registration is successful, it
notify either success or the failure
to the respective stakeholders.
Now, sometime in a given domain boundaries,
you need to orchestrate this multi-step
process, this task, and how this
can happen
in event of an architecture.
It could happen via applying
the orchestration patterns. So how this happened, let's
look into the registration device flow.
Once we get a registration registration
device event alert from the devices,
we first
start the workflow,
validate the devices, register the
devices,
and if the registration is successfully complete,
we publish the device registration is
successful as an event.
Or if it is failed, we notify
to the end users they're saying that or the
admins that OK the event has failed
the registration has failed and.
We end our workflow and this could be done
applying the step function so the choreography
and the orchestration both are important
choreography for applying the.
The multi-step process within the service
domain and choreography for applying
the communication across the domains, right?
So that was another pattern which we leveraged
for Phyllis RSGU's case.
Last but not least again,
the integration we so far
talked about a lot of integration between the different
components, but often
the. Applying the integration
can be hard for the developers. They
have to spend an undeficiated
effort to build this integration logic
and how we can solve that. So for take
example, there are a lot of events which has been emitted
right by our transactional system. Let's take example
of Dynamo DB,
and we want to apply certain filtering on those
events, not all events we want to respond or
act upon, act upon, right? And
then we want to also enrich these events,
right? And then we want to.
Route this event to the respective targets
and we execute the business, uh, sorry,
bus business processes accordingly so
all this thing can happen applying the
event bridge pipe which provide us a
capability to build a low code
no code integration pattern. So in this slide
what we see from left hand side where the Dynamo
DB stream is emitting the, the
messages which can be then.
Enrich, transform, and then distributed
to the different consumer via EventBridge
is seamlessly happening without writing
a single line of code. So this
also
accelerate your entire event driven architecture
implementation journey. Now with this, I
hand over to the Shirini so that we go through
the end to end architecture and the
solution for Phillips RSG Bridge use
case, what we were able to.
Built upon Sweni,
over to you. Thank you, Anand.
This felt like 10 years' worth
of knowledge in 30 minutes crash
course,
and it's also the joke for me because
we went through the same exercise
last year when we were actually trying to
solve for this.
One critical thing that I missed telling
earlier that Legacy M2M
system that I was talking about is
not Philip's own, it's a third party system,
and that was the fundamental challenge
or why somebody could say, oh, you
build the system,
why do you need to reverse engineer
to figure out how the system behaves or how
the system performs.
In order for so resetting
the context, right? So we have
on the left side the devices.
That have an agent that cannot be
updated.
And then on the right side we have the Legacy
M2M services, which is going end
of life.
We have to replace that
with a modern system, which we
have done, and many of our
existing systems were able to migrate
except for these 20,000 devices.
The main requirement was
we cannot touch the devices.
To connect to this modern systems. Now
how do we do?
That's where the bridge comes in and
Anand has been talking about RSGA bridge.
So let me walk you
through how.
The overall architecture has come through.
So the first thing that we had to do was
we had to run a workshop and there are 3
things that Anan talked about
understand your domain,
understand how your events are,
what patterns you can apply, and
how all of those things are going to come
together. So this,
um, right now, the, the
existing architecture, the flow that I'll talk
through is existing architecture. So we
have these medical devices connecting
into the
ERs private link.
Um, because we don't want any of our
healthcare data flowing out of
internet. It goes through a network load
balancer to an application load balancer
and into the legacy M2M backend.
This flow is important, and we had
to start here
because we want to understand how
these request responses were.
And this is where the domain driven design design
actually came into a
big help for us,
and we identified 5 core
domains. Um, there were more, but
for the purpose of this, uh,
talk,
we'll keep it very simple what Anand
was talking about
how the devices register into the
back end system,
how the devices upload the files.
What are the alerts that get generated,
either from the device or in the back
end? What is the heartbeat
that comes along to the back end
saying that Am I up?
And lastly,
to make the property updates
onto these devices, how can we push
those properties? So these are the core 5
core domains that we have identified.
And while identifying, I think there
are a couple of patterns that evolved,
and one of the pattern was for us
to say,
OK, within the bounded context
of this particular type of
events,
what should be the workload be
in some, because in case of registration,
it was no brainer. It happens only once.
It doesn't happen every day. You register once
and you're done with it.
So our choice was to
use a lambda service to
properly process those events.
Whereas when you try to upload
the files, these log files
are happening
every day. In some cases these devices
are large
because sometimes devices don't connect for
a couple of days and suddenly we see
burst of like 100 MB worth of
files and you can't process them
with the serverless.
So that's where we had to use
Amazon ECS Fargate
uh to process these long running
uh processes.
Wherein the files used to get stored
in uh Amazon Simple Storage
Service. Now once
we have a good understanding of
how the workloads are,
now the second pattern was, OK, we have
all these events. Now what do we do with these
events?
In some case, we had to
actually store them in, in
the Dynamo DB.
Um, we had actually Dynamo DB streams
enabled with the Kinesis adapter
so that we know where
this event has to be routed to
now, as Anand was also saying that
for us time was a constraint.
We had to put it in a
place in such a way that during the
migration period of a particular
device,
if something goes wrong we have to be able
to replay it.
So we had used the Amazon
event bridge pipe.
To filter these events, to be able
to know which route or which
service or which queue to go into,
and,
Um,
essentially the even bus is the one that is actually
processing this, so
the low code, no code kind
of capability,
uh, provided us the capability to
create these filters on the flight
when needed.
So some of the key takeaways
I would say is we have figured out what the
events are, what, where the events get
stored,
and how they would get routed
now the.
The fun part was, as I was
saying, this is all about
making the system
working during the migration time period.
So this is where we had to choose what
else can we actually
take from the tool set of the patterns
that are available to us from the event-driven.
So these events as they were
being processed in the event bridge,
we had defined the respective
cues in which where the events
can go in
and if, as I was saying, if at all we
had to replay, we could know what
what the, how the systems were behaving
this gave us like a good
view into
um how the events came into the
system, how they were being processed,
and
one of the complexity was.
We had to deal with
complex workflows.
In simple cases where
there is just a simple request response,
it was a very straightforward process
and given the time constraint that we were
dealing with step functions gave
us the best possible
implementation
where we could really see
and figure out how
each of the steps were being performed
and.
If need be,
if we have to go back and change
something, it was pretty easy for
us to go back and change,
and, and trust me, we did the migration,
um, over a period of 3 weeks
in the month of December,
and we were almost deploying
every day into the production
some other services, so the
microservices allowed us to
be able to,
uh, deploy the changes that we want.
Um, the, um, even,
uh, the even bridge, uh,
filtering allowed us to say, hey,
should we turn off this filter? Should we tweak
something,
and then
these services eventually talk to
the
more modern IOT system that we
are building.
So the outcomes were good.
That's why I'm on this stage.
Um, we were successfully able to
bridge those 20,000 devices
from the legacy system to the new IOT system,
all on the AWSRLS.
We also were able to do it
without the cost of that 20
million that we talked about earlier.
Avoiding the field trips.
And then of course
there was
no interruption
so we achieved zero touch
0 down,
fully compliant,
and
I felt like
whatever that we were doing was not short
term. It was not a bridge for a short term,
but it's a bridge for us to go into the future.
So in summary, I would say,
I think.
If you ask me,
Anand was exactly right. We have
to start with domain, and it's not
technology, and it is in this case,
our teams were very well versed
understanding what serviceability workflows looked
like, but still we had
to understand a system that we were
not aware of. So
even storming domain driven
design gave us the right severalless boundaries.
And I was also talking about how
loose coupling beats tight efficiency.
The architecture, which is
the human driven architecture, which is a mental model
for us, was to be able to adapt
to the API-driven microservices,
and
I would also say that we had to mix a little
bit of choreography and some type of
services.
And use orchestration within the
services so that we're able to
process them properly in a multi-step, uh,
multi-step, uh,
um, changes.
And then lastly
we think in platform
and we cannot think in just point
solutions because
once we have this platform
that is up and running it scales
and it scales across multiple devices,
multiple years
so this is what I would like to end with
the talk.
I hope we have given a good insight into
how.
What the Phillips journey was over
those last six months
before we get to that December 31st, 2024
and.
Uh, hopefully you know and resonate
this, um, uh, the
process that we went through. Hopefully you can apply
it on in your own journeys
where you have legacy systems that you deal
with.
Thank you.
Thanks, really, and, uh.
Thank you. And
you folks can also, you know, learn more
about the different,
even different architecture pattern from our
server slang.
So right, and you can scan the QR
code. It will lend you to the website and then
you will find much more pattern than what
we talked about and also the different type of implementation
of the some of the pattern which
we also covered as part of our talk
today. So with that, yeah, as I mentioned,
thank you. Thank you